SO IMPORTANT IN AN EVER-CHANGING
CITY.
THAT AND SO MUCH MORE IS ALL
AHEAD.
>>> WE BEGIN THIS MORNING WITH
MIXED SIGNS IN THE COVID
VACCINATION EFFORT.
THE CENTERS FOR DISEASE CONTROL
AND PREVENTION NOW SAYS MORE
THAN 101 MILLION AMERICANS ARE
FULLY VACCINATED.
MORE THAN 43% HAVE RECEIVED AT
LEAST ONE DOSE.
THE AVERAGE DAILY CASE COUNT IS
DOWN 16%.
BUT THERE ARE CONCERNS ABOUT
VACCINE HESITANCY COUPLED WITH
NEW WARNINGS ABOUT VARIANTS, ALL
WHILE RESTRICTIONS ARE BEING
RAMPED UP IN THE PACIFIC
NORTHWEST, WITH WASHINGTON STATE
AND OREGON BATTLING WHAT'S BEING
CALLED A FOURTH SURGE.
MICHAEL GEORGE IS HERE WITH THE
LATEST.
MICHAEL, GOOD MORNING.
>> Reporter: DANA, GOOD MORNING.
RIGHT NOW A THIRD OF THE COUNTRY
HAS BEEN FULLY VACCINATED.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF NEW
VACCINATIONS IS DROPPING, THERE
ARE SOME ENCOURAGING SIGNS.
>> WELCOME BACK, EVERYONE,
WELCOME HOME!
>> Reporter: THERE WAS NO HIDING
THE ENTHUSIASM AS DISNEYLAND
REOPENED YESTERDAY AFTER 13
MONTHS.
♪ IT'S A SMALL WORLD AFTER ALL ♪
>> Reporter: THE PARK IS LIMITED
TO 20,000 CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS A
DAY.
WHILE IN KENTUCKY, CHURCHILL
DOWNS WENT ALL OUT WHEN IT
REOPENED YESTERDAY.
IN MICHIGAN, WHERE BARS AND
RESTAURANTS CAN OPERATE AT 65%
CAPACITY, OFFICIALS ARE USING A
CARROT AND STICK APPROACH.
GET THE VACCINATION RATE UP AND
MORE PLACES WILL OPEN UP.
>> IF YOU'VE BEEN WAITING AND
SEEING, IF YOU'RE ONE OF THE
LET'S WAIT AND SEE, I THINK
WE'VE WAITED AND SAW ENOUGH, AND
IT'S TIME TO COME DOWN.
>> Reporter: A NEW CDC STUDY
ADDRESSES VACCINE HESITANT
PEOPLE FINDING IT WAS ANXIETY,
NOT THE VACCINE, THAT CAUSED
THOSE SHORT-TERM REACTIONS TO
THE JOHNSON & JOHNSON SHOT
REPORTED EARLIER THIS MONTH.
THE RESULTS MAY BE IN HOSPITALS
WHERE PEOPLE WHO REFUSED VACCINE
PROTECTION ARE NOW FILLING UP
BEDS IN INTENSIVE CARE UNITS.
>> I HAVE A COUPLE OF PATIENTS
IN PEORIA WHO SAID I HAD THE
OPTION TO GET VACCINATED AND I
TURNED IT DOWN AND I HIGHLY
REGRET IT.
NOW THAT THEY'RE SICK, THEY'RE
LIKE WHAT CAN I DO TO GET
BETTER?
>> Reporter: BUT VACCINATION
RATES ARE SLOWING.
TAKE ARKANSAS.
IT'S ONE OF MORE THAN TEN STATES
NOT ORDERING ALL AVAILABLE
VACCINE DOSES.
36% OF ARKANSAS RESIDENTS HAVE
RECEIVED AT LEAST ONE DOSE, WELL
BELOW THE NATIONAL TOTAL.
FOR THE UNVACCINATED, THEY MAY
WANTING TO LISTEN TO WHAT DR.
ANTHONY FAUCI SAID YESTERDAY.
>> BOTTOM LINE OF MY MESSAGE, A,
GET VACCINATED.
AND IF YOU'RE HAVING A TWO-DOSE
REGIMEN, MAKE SURE YOU GET THAT
SECOND DOSE.
>> Reporter: NOW, DR. FAUCI ALSO
POINTED OUT THAT AN ESTIMATED 8%
OF PEOPLE WHO RECEIVED THEIR
FIRST DOSE DIDN'T SHOW UP FOR
THEIR SECOND.
THEY MAY STILL HAVE SOME LEVEL
OF PROTECTION B